Speaker 1: Let's instead try Billy from California,
Billy from California.
You're on the air.
Unidentified: David, hey, a yes.
Speaker 4: Oh, sorry, I just wanted to talk
quickly about actually masking so based on
CDC guidelines, if you're vaccinated now,
you don't have to wear a mask outside.
I started working in my downtown office again
since I've been fully vaccinated and I'm walking
to the office every day and I'm not wearing
my mask, but I see everyone else wearing a
mask and I almost feel like obligated to do
so.
Just kind of like.
I don't know, like a sense of camaraderie
or like, hey, I'm like, you know, trying to
be safe and look out for other people, too.
But now
Speaker 1: hold on.
When you say you're weird, when you say you
walk into your office not wearing a mask,
you're not saying inside the masks are still
required.
Right?
You're saying outside.
Speaker 4: Oh, sure, sure, sure.
No, I meant like, I park you away from the
office.
And I want to as I'm walking through downtown
to my office, there's, you know, people wearing
masks and, you know, you walk by them and
they kind of look at you funny if you're not
wearing a mask and it's like, I'm back, you
know, you don't want to just start shouting
people on your backs unvaccinated.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I know I'm seeing the
same thing in a lot of different places.
I mean, listen, here's the deal.
If there's a line at the grocery store and
I'm standing outside in the line and everybody's
wearing a mask, I'm going to put the mask
on because that's kind of like a specific
situation.
And so I want to be kind of part of the team
when I go out running now, there's still a
lot of people wearing masks and I'm not wearing
a mask.
You know, I am fully vaccinated.
I don't think we ever really needed masks
in that situation.
I but I followed the CDC guidelines all along.
I continue to follow them, I think.
And and I have a high level of comfort.
Nobody has given me a dirty look.
But if they did, I wouldn't care.
I'd be totally comfortable.
I'm doing what the CDC says.
So I think it's a very personal thing.
Some people are more impacted by the social
pressure.
Some are not.
I think the important thing is, are we following
the guidelines?
Speaker 4: Fair enough.
Yeah, well, I agree, and I guess downtown's
a little different because you do have it's
not crowded.
Yeah, but at the same time, it's not far.
So when you're walking down the sidewalks,
you are like a few feet from people.
But again, the data shows that that's low
transmission rate.
Speaker 1: And, you know, I'm also wondering
is when I see that even though the guidelines
have changed, I'm wondering No.
One, are these people aware of the change,
but they're just not vaccinated.
Sure.
So that's why they're doing it.
Or have people not even heard about the change
yet?
That's also possible.
Speaker 4: That's another thing, too.
Like maybe we're more obviously we're more
in tune to it.
Right.
Read the news and stuff like that.
But I don't think everybody does that.
I don't think there's been a big I haven't
seen any ads or PSA is really stating things.
Speaker 1: I agree.
And there's been no commercials saying you
no longer have to wear your mask outside.
I think over the next couple of months, though,
it'll roll out and you'll see fewer and fewer
outdoor masks.
Speaker 4: Yeah, another thing, too, if you
just for a minute, as as we're kind of reopening
and getting back together, we finally were
able to visit with my family, you know, my
brother, my sisters and my mom and my dad,
since everyone's fully vaccinated, you know,
we brought our kids over there and it was
really great to be around them, but.
You know, as we're going forward and kind
of reopening and getting back together with
people, yeah, I do still have some family
members that are our Magga or anti Baxters,
and I know they're not going to get the vaccine.
And it just kind of hurts because it's like,
well, I want to see these people and I want
to be around these people.
Right.
And I don't really have any ill will as like
a family to family.
But I mean,
Speaker 1: that's just going to be tough.
I've heard a lot of stories like that where
I know so many people.
I don't personally know anyone not getting
vaccinated, but lots of the people I know
do know people not getting vaccinated.
And many of them are saying, we've just told
them we will only be around you outside if
you're not vaccinated, period.
Some are being even more extreme and saying,
listen, I'm just not going to see you at all.
But a lot of a lot I know are saying, listen,
we're just going to have to see each other
outside if you refuse to get vaccinated.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah, and it's tough with
young kids, I my wife and I are pretty protective,
so I don't even know if we would be too comfortable
with that.
Sure.
To each their own.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's going to be interesting going forward.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, thank you
for the call.
Speaker 4: Take care.
I hope you're doing well because you didn't
mention that you were doing well before you
started calls, so, you know,
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Thank you for asking.
Yes, very good.
OK.
All right.
Thanks everybody else here soon.
OK.
A lot of concern for whether I am doing well
today